it's going to disappear one day it's
like a miracle it will disappear
president Trump's response to the
unfolding coronavirus pandemic has
included a mix of wishful thinking and
misinformation we have it totally under
control it's one person coming in from
China and his message has often
contradicted health officials as well as
state and local government we have very
little problem in this country at this
moment I'm declaring a public health
emergency of international concern now
the virus you know a lot of people think
that goes away in April with the heat
this virus is probably with us beyond
this season our bond if I yawn this year
we're dealing with a serious virus that
we're taking very seriously
this is their new hoax the Democrats are
politicizing the corona virus
on average you lose from 26,000 to
70,000 or so and in some cases more from
the flu and we're talking about a much
smaller range the mortality of this is
multiple times
what seasonal flu is we don't have
enough tests today anybody that needs a
test it's a test we have not received
enough tests
I am very frustrated with the federal
government I'm also battling against
frankly the mixed messages from the
federal government forget the chatter
forget what you're hearing from the
federal government thank you please
appreciate very much great joke I'm
working on getting the boss today this I
may not be successful but we're working
on it
known as skelet 1 to 10 how would you
rate your response to this crisis I'd
ready to attend I think we've done a
great job this is a pandemic I felt it
was a pandemic long before it was called
a pandemic
you